so let's focus on good versus bad
billionaires what do I mean by this the
good billionaires in a country typically
tend to be from industry such as
technology manufacturing pharmaceutical
these are industries where it is all
about that person's skill and talent
which is leading to this wealth creation
on the other end the bad billion is tend
to be from industries such as real
estate mining and what do I mean by that
that in these industries a lot of the
wealth creation is done by gaming the
system or by having good government
connections and I think that that is
that any nation will have a few bad
billionaires but you have too many bad
was as good billionaires that is a
problem
now take the case of the United States
in the United States in fact a number of
good billionaires far outnumbers the
number of bad billionaires in this
nation and that is a good thing it
because even though the number of
billion is like in this country is very
large even as a share of the total
economy but the fact that you have more
good versus bad billionaires means that
the in general wealth creation is still
respected in this country so you have
people like Bill Gates Warren Buffett
who are great philanthropists and so
therefore they're widely respected or
you have the likes of the Mark
Zuckerberg who create wealth by these
kind of innovative applications
technologies and products and that's
really what leads to them being
respected as well now there's a very
interesting case of Donald Trump who we
all like to speak about there are few
people who will even dispute whether
he's really a billionaire but I think
that's assume that he is one and it's
true now that by the classic definition
he would be a bad billionaire because a
lot of the wealth comes from industries
such as real estate and many people
think he's created this wealth by sort
of being able to use government
connections and other kind of unfair
means but the good thing is that because
in this nation there are more good than
bad billionaires people still respect
billionaires in general there's not a
revolt against billionaires unlike
Russia or Mexico in those nations
there is absolutely no chance that a
billionaire would be able to run for
office that would be held against him or
her and the other good thing is that
Trump is been able to sort of project
himself as a blue-collar billionaire and
I think that that is where it sort of
you know gets interesting that he's able
to project as someone who you know sort
of can relate to the masses speak with
the masses and that is why I think that
he remains popular even though he is a
billionaire whose wealth is arguably
coming from not great sources and would
typically be classified in the bad
billionaire basket